Douées de langage,
regroupées en familles solidaires,
les orques sont
des chasseresses redoutables.
Leur puissance
hors norme leur permet de terrasser
les plus grosses espèces de l'océan.
Elles sèment
la terreur sur leur passage.
Intelligentes et organisées,
elles s'adaptent à tous les milieux.
Dans un enfer stérile
au bout du monde
elles ont développé d'incroyables
techniques de chasse pour survivre.
Pourtant, aujourd'hui,
leur avenir est menacé.
David Reichert,
cinéaste animalier, veut percer
quelques-uns de leurs secrets.
Armé de sa caméra,
il va tenter de
partager l'intimité des animaux
de ces terres
désolées pour mieux comprendre
les relations qui existent
entre prédateurs et proies.
Suivez ce guide exceptionnel.
Partagez avec lui
cette expérience unique.
Plongez dans le monde
des titans pour une immersion totale
au cœur d'un des milieux
les plus hostiles de la planète.
Perdu dans les eaux
glaciales du sud de l'océan Indien,
un archipel bien loin du paradis.
Crozet, sans cesse
balayé par les tempêtes,
c'est l'un des lieux
les plus inhospitaliers au monde.
Le vent, impitoyable maître
des lieux y concentre inlassablement
la pluie, la neige
ou la grêle, 310 jours par an.
Il offre parfois
l'aumône d'un rayon de soleil,
mais en général,
il ne véhicule que la tourmente.
Septembre,
début du printemps austral.
Le bateau de pêche
Île Bourbon affronte ce climat sans pitié,
en quête de l'un des plus rares
et des meilleurs
poissons du monde, la légine.
Découvert à la fin du XXᵉ siècle,
cet animal est vendu à prix d'or.
Très apprécié
sur le marché asiatique,
il l'est aussi par un prédateur
à l'appétit gargantuesque.
Un dauphin géant de huit tonnes,
l'orque épaulard.
David Reichert,
spécialiste des mammifères marins
se passionne
pour ce superprédateur.
Il est témoin
d'un comportement qui met en évidence
l'incroyable intelligence des orques.
Comme les autres poissons
qui vivent ici,
la légine habite
les profondeurs abyssales.
Inaccessibles aux cétacés,
elle ne fait pas partie
de leur régime alimentaire.
Les orques,
opportunistes et curieuses de tout,
se sont adaptés à la présence
récente des palangriers dans la région.
Elles ont découvert la pêche sans effort.
Il suffit d'attendre
que les lignes remontent le poisson.
Aujourd'hui, elles raffolent
de la livraison à domicile.
Malheureusement, de nombreux
bateaux pirates sillonnent la région
en quête de la précieuse légine.
Ces hors-la-loi n'hésitent pas
à massacrer à coup de dynamite
leurs rivales trop gourmandes.
Des orques
devenues méfiantes envers notre espèce
ne renoncent pas
pour autant à cette pêche facile.
Les constats scientifiques sont terribles,
50 % des orques
de la région ont disparu depuis 1995,
exterminées par des hommes
sans scrupules.
David Reichert
a embarqué sur l’Île Bourbon,
l'un des rares bateaux
autorisés dans la zone
et l'un des seuls moyens
pour rallier les îles Crozet.
Le but de ce long voyage,
étudier sur place
le comportement des orques en danger.
David est coutumier
des plongées extrêmes
et des situations périlleuses.
Rien ne l'arrête
pour approcher les sujets qu'il étudie.
Pour la première fois,
un plongeur va se mettre à l'eau
à proximité d'un bateau de pêche,
synonyme pour les orques
de repas facile
mais aussi de danger mortel.
Quelle sera
la réaction des prédatrices ?
Une jeune femelle approche.
Immédiatement,
elle est rappelée par sa mère.
Chez les orques,
l'autorité ne se discute pas.
Les orques ont évité David.
La prochaine rencontre
aura lieu dans l'archipel de Crozet.
Les chasseresses
ont là-bas un rendez-vous vital
avec des proies
plus traditionnelles que les légines.
Chaque année, début septembre,
après dix mois
passés sans sortir de l'eau,
les éléphants de mer reviennent
de leur longue migration
dans les eaux antarctiques.
Ils doivent gagner la terre
ferme pour se reproduire.
L'occasion pour les orques de mettre
en œuvre des techniques de chasse
qu'elles se transmettent de génération
en génération depuis des millénaires.
La présence des palangriers
a-t-elle altéré
la transmission de cette culture ?
et bouleversé
le comportement alimentaire des cétacés ?
il y a t-il eu des changements
consécutifs aux tueries des hommes ?
La population d'éléphants
de mer est-elle en augmentation
face à la diminution
du nombre d'orques ?
Pour le savoir,
l'explorateur va se fondre
dans la vie secrète de ces animaux.
Pendant quatre mois,
David partagera leur quotidien
au cœur d'une nature hostile
où la survie
est une affaire de chaque instant.
Ici, les animaux
ne sont pas chassés par les hommes.
Ils ne devraient pas avoir peur de moi.
C'est l'endroit idéal
pour découvrir leur intimité
et comprendre les liens étroits
qui unissent prédateurs et proies.
J'arrive juste à temps
pour le grand rendez-vous.
Le retour des éléphants commence.
Ce mâle adulte vient de nager
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres
dans l'océan Austral
pour rejoindre Crozet.
Le colosse hisse
péniblement ses cinq mètres de long
et ses trois tonnes
sur la plage qui l'a vu naître.
Il est mu par une pulsion irrésistible,
le sexe.
Une femelle émerge à son tour.
Elle va mettre au monde et allaiter
le bébé qu'elle a conçu ici même,
il y a un an.
Pour le pachyderme, elle naît
de l'écume telle une Aphrodite.
C'est un spectacle
auquel il ne peut résister.
Pour se reproduire, l'éléphant de mer
doit rassembler un harem de femelles
et devenir pacha.
Seul moyen d'y parvenir,
se montrer le plus fort,
s'imposer à tous les autres mâles.
La femelle, 5 à 7 fois
moins lourde, doit se soumettre
en guise de parade amoureuse,
une démonstration de force
et une sérieuse morsure
la persuade d'intégrer le futur harem.
Ce pacha
va devoir protéger son précieux butin
de la convoitise
des autres prétendants.
Un rival jaloux pointe déjà la trompe
et évalue ses chances
de conquérir un territoire.
La place
de reproducteur est très convoitée.
Sur la plage,
il n'y aura qu'un seul pacha.
Les conflits sont inévitables.
Une autre femelle arrive.
Impressionnée
par la concupiscence des mâles,
la malheureuse perçoit trop tard
les tonnes de muscles qui foncent sur elle
Pour la future maman,
le voyage finit en tragédie.
Son bébé ne verra jamais
la terre que sa mère avait choisie
pour lui donner la vie.
Attraper les proies sur la plage
témoigne d'une véritable adaptation
à des conditions difficiles.
Ici, le poisson est rare et inaccessible.
Les orques sont condamnées
à chasser d'autres mammifères marins.
Le clan des cétacés est averti.
La chasse a été bonne.
La proie est relâchée
pour que les jeunes apprennent à chasser.
De leur initiation
aux différentes méthodes de capture
dépendra leur survie.
L'éducation et la transmission
du savoir sont essentielles.
Cette scène peut paraître cruelle,
mais elle démontre
à quel point les orques sont sociables
et mutuellement protectrices.
La mise à mort
est donnée par une jeune femelle.
Opportunistes,
les oiseaux profitent aussi du festin.
Ici, chaque protéine est vitale.
La lourde caisse recèle
de quoi permettre à David
d'être autonome
jusqu'au retour du bateau de pêche
dans quatre mois.
Ces oiseaux, des skuas,
confirment les suspicions de David.
Ici, les animaux
sont loin d'être farouches.
Installé près du harem,
le cinéaste se trouve aux premières loges
pour étudier les interactions
entre orques et éléphants de mer.
En quelques jours,
le pacha a rassemblé
plusieurs dizaines de femelles.
un travail épuisant.
Jour et nuit, sur la brèche,
il dirige les arrivantes vers son harem
et interdit
à ses concurrents d'approcher.
Pour l'heure,
c'est le repos du guerrier.
Cela n'empêche pas les chasseresses
de venir voir si une de
ces délicieuses masses de graisse
ne se trouve pas
à portée de mâchoires.
L'épaisse couche de lard des éléphants,
représente un fabuleux apport d'énergie.
En clair,
ce sont de véritables mets de luxe.
Un mâle reconnaissable
à son aileron triangulaire
de près de deux mètres de haut
est accompagné par deux femelles.
Leur nageoire dorsale
est plus petite et courbe.
Les orques vivent
en régime matriarcal.
Une femelle dominante
dirige un groupe très uni
constitué de ses sœurs, de ses filles
et des enfants
de tout le monde.
Il n'y a pas de couple au sein du clan.
Comme chez les hommes,
l'inceste est tabou.
Les reproductions se font uniquement
entre membres de familles différentes.
La matriarche, très imposante,
atteint peut-être sept mètres de long.
On n'a jamais déploré
d'attaques d'orques sur l'homme
mais je ne peux
m'empêcher de me poser la question.
Et si j'étais le premier
de mon espèce au menu du jour ?
Le groupe s'éloigne
paisiblement en direction du sud de l'île.
Cette rencontre ravive
une scène dans la mémoire du cinéaste.
En 1988, sur cette même plage,
une jeune orque inexpérimentée
s'échoue après avoir
essayé de capturer une proie.
Heureusement, un groupe
de scientifiques se trouvent là
et l'aide à se remettre à l'eau.
Le retour à la mer est
l'occasion d'une explosion de joie
chez les cétacés
comme chez les hommes.
Un drame a été évité.
Ces images filmées en amateur
ont fait le tour du monde.
Est-ce la rescapée
que j'ai rencontrée aujourd'hui ?
Ce face à face était-il une forme
d'interrogation à l'égard de mon espèce
alors que
j'y percevais une possible menace ?
Qu'est-ce que je représente
pour ces superprédateurs ?
Questions fascinantes.
David, heureux,
pense avoir établi
un authentique contact
avec les géantes
qu'il est venu saluer.
Malgré leur force,
les mâles adultes ne sont pas
à l'abri d'une attaque des super dauphins
et celui-ci peut en témoigner.
Les éléphants risquent
leur vie lorsqu'ils viennent à terre.
Au large, en cas de danger
ils peuvent sonder
à plus de 1500 mètres,
profondeur à laquelle les orques
sont incapables de les poursuivre.
En revanche,
près des hauts-fonds,
ils deviennent des proies vulnérables.
Une jeune orque,
éloignée du groupe
se retrouve face
à un puissant éléphant de mer.
La curiosité l'emporte,
mais le mastodonte ne fuit pas.
Au contraire,
il avance, sûr de lui,
enfin presque.
Un éléphant de cette taille
est un adversaire dangereux
pour une orque seule.
Première chose à faire,
repli stratégique
en direction du clan.
Les orques connaissent
aussi un vieil adage,
l'union fait la force.
Cet éléphant profite
de la passivité de son homologue
pour agrandir son territoire.
Il a un fief,
mais pas encore de belles dames.
La solitude
lui porte sur les nerfs, visiblement.
Le temps est venu
d'aller faire un tour ailleurs.
Je décide de franchir
le petit volcan derrière lequel
j'ai souvent vu disparaître les orques.
Je suis curieux
de savoir ce qui les attire là-bas.
Voilà un parfait endroit
pour mes prises de vue.
Ici par temps calme,
le fond rocheux me permettra
de profiter de la transparence de l'eau,
chose rare ici,
avec une mer
sans cesse recommencée.
Les orques ne viennent pas là pour rien.
Il n'y a pas
que les éléphants de mer dans la vie.
Cette plage encaissée abrite
une colonie de manchots royaux,
des dizaines
de milliers de couples.
Aux yeux des super dauphins,
un garde-manger
généreusement garni toute l'année.
Au centre de cette foule,
les poussins de l'année dernière
sont réunis en crèche pendant
que leurs parents sont partis pêcher.
Ils sont couverts
d'un duvet doux comme une laine.
Ils garderont ce chaud manteau
protecteur pendant plus de neuf mois.
Tant qu'ils n'ont pas leurs plumes
et leurs muscles
d'adulte pour affronter la mer,
ils doivent patienter
et attendre la becquée.
Ces bébés affamés
semblent m'avoir adopté.
L'appel du ventre, peut-être.
L'élevage du jeune dure presque un an
et exige un prodigieux
dévouement de la part des adultes.
Contre vents et tempêtes,
père et mère enchaînent
des voyages
d'une dizaine de jours, aller-retour.
La zone riche en nourriture se trouve
à des centaines de kilomètres de là,
parfois près de 1000.
Pour trouver crustacés,
mollusques et petits poissons,
ils plongent s'il le faut,
par 500 mètres de fond.
Le jabot garni,
ils regagnent l'île
et retrouvent leur unique rejeton
parmi des milliers d'autres
en l'identifiant à son cri.
Les manchots partent
à la pêche en groupe.
Ainsi, en cas de danger,
ils multiplient
leurs chances de survie.
Belle occasion
pour les orques de travailler
l'une de leurs
techniques de chasse collective.
D'abord la discrétion, silence radio.
Tous les membres du clan
connaissent leur place dans la patrouille.
Juste avant l'attaque,
chacun précise aux autres sa position
par des clics d'écholocation.
Quand tout le monde est prêt,
la matriarche donne le signal.
Les manchots sont agiles et rapides.
Les attraper représente
une grande dépense d'énergie
pour un maigre repas.
Le prix de la survie quand il n'y a
rien d'autre à se mettre sous la dent.
Le barrage des orques franchi,
revenir de la pêche représente encore
une sérieuse épreuve pour les oiseaux.
Après tous ces exploits,
le poussin affamé
peut enfin ouvrir un large bec.
Septembre s'achève,
le pacha a rassemblé
plus d'une centaine de femelles.
Un record probablement lié
à la diminution des effectifs d'orques.
Pourtant, les chasseresses
ne relâchent pas la pression.
Et pour cause,
peu après son arrivée,
chaque femelle
va mettre au monde un petit.
De la chair tendre en perspective.
Pour les oiseaux, le placenta est
l'occasion d'un festin de protéines.
Les premiers cris qu'échangent
la mère et le jeune sont décisifs.
Avec l'odeur,
ils leur permettront
de se reconnaître dans la colonie.
Les yeux à peine ouverts,
bébé éléphanteau tète
le lait le plus riche du monde.
Dix fois plus de graisse
et de calories que dans le lait de vache.
Le transfert d'énergie
de la mère au rejeton est si parfait
qu'en trois semaines
le poupon quadruple son poids
et peut être sevré.
Pour le pacha,
tout déplacement est exténuant.
Il continue pourtant à s'approprier
et à féconder chaque nouvelle arrivante.
Durant les deux mois
et demi de la saison des amours,
il ne mange pas
et perd quinze kilos par jour.
Cette vitalité n'est possible
que grâce aux réserves de graisse
accumulées au cours des dix mois passés
à engloutir poissons de fond et calamar.
Mais l'animal n'est pas
au bout de ses peines.
Le harem est cerné
par les prétendants.
La présence de toutes
ces femelles stimule leur libido
et nombre de ces célibataires essaient
de perpétuer leur patrimoine génétique
en catimini.
Le pacha menace.
Ces protestations sont
amplifiées par une trompe démesurée
véritable organe de résonance,
preuve de virilité.
Plus l'appendice nasal est grand,
plus le son émis est puissant.
Cela suffit souvent
à dissuader le maraudeur sexuel.
Mais quand un prétendant déguerpit
à droite, un autre s'introduit à gauche.
Impossible de tout contrôler.
Des analyses ADN ont prouvé
que contrairement aux apparences,
le pacha est loin
d'être le père de tous les bébés.
Ces excessives décharges d'hormones
peuvent dégénérer en sévères conflits.
Un mâle déterminé ose défier
le seigneur local.
L'enjeu du combat ?
Le harem,
ses plaisirs et ses peines.
Près de ces titans,
je mesure la puissance de l'instinct
qui préside à la transmission des gènes.
J'y vois le symbole de la résistance
aux conditions extrêmes du milieu.
L'image même
de la lutte pour la vie.
Je veux connaître avec les orques
une expérience d'une intensité comparable.
Je vais retourner à cet endroit où l'eau
transparente me permettra de les admirer.
Je reconnais
la matriarche à sa taille imposante.
Il me semble,
à son regard rempli d'expérience,
qu'elle connaît les hommes.
Est-ce la femelle
remise à l'eau par les scientifiques ?
Je me plais à l'imaginer.
Je voudrais éterniser cet instant,
en savoir davantage
sur elle et les siens.
Une fois encore,
la rencontre est furtive.
Le peuple des hommes et celui
de la mer n'ont guère d'occasions
d'engager le dialogue.
La culture acquise par les orques est
possible grâce à une longévité importante.
Les mâles vivent environ 50 ans
et les femelles
peuvent devenir octogénaires.
Le régime matriarcal
récompense l'âge et l'expérience.
Chasseresses exemplaires,
les orques ne passent que 10 %
de leur temps à satisfaire
leurs besoins alimentaires.
Elles consacrent le reste au repos
aux jeux tendres et sensuels
et à l'éducation des jeunes.
Véritable transmission d'un savoir,
cette école de la mer peut durer 20 ans.
L'harmonie du groupe est
sans cesse entretenue.
On se touche,
on se caresse et surtout on se parle.
Les scientifiques ont montré
que les orques d'un même bassin océanique
possèdent un langage commun.
Plus incroyable encore,
au sein de chaque clan,
il existe même un dialecte.
Frustré par la brièveté
de ses entrevues,
David tente le grand coup,
le face à face avec les géantes.
C'est au cœur de leur territoire,
derrière la forêt d'algues,
qu'il imagine le rendez-vous.
Les orques ne pénètrent jamais
dans ces forêts impressionnantes
de macrocystis.
Les tiges très solides
de ces algues filiformes
pouvant mesurer plus
de 50 mètres, seraient un piège mortel.
La matriarche surprend le plongeur.
Elle émet des cliquetis rapides.
Elle communique
avec le reste de sa troupe,
qui se tient sagement à distance.
Prudente, la responsable
du clan est venue en reconnaissance.
Comme elle est arrivée, elle a disparu.
À nouveau, la méfiance a été
le maître-mot de la rencontre.
L'arrivée d'un groupe
de manchots confirme le départ des orques.
Oubliant sa déception,
David se laisse envahir
par la grâce de cette envolée.
Tiens !
On dirait que j'ai
un invité surprise ce soir.
Le combattant anéanti par sa défaite
ne sera pas encore pacha cette saison.
Peut-être aura-t-il
plus de chance l'année prochaine.
Les plus forts
n'y parviennent que vers l'âge de huit ans
mais jamais plus
de deux années consécutives.
Une telle dépense
d'énergie les épuise.
Sans paraître agressif,
ce mastodonte incarne
quand même un danger.
Impossible d'approcher de ma tente.
Aujourd'hui
le temps est superbe.
Un événement.
Un brin de toilette finira
par me faire oublier ma nuit blanche.
Les bébés dégustent l'innocence
et le lait de leurs premiers jours
près du ventre tiède de leur maman.
Instant de sérénité, magnifiée
par un doux parfum de vacances
et de sieste.
Les orques profitent
elles aussi du calme pour dormir.
Mais leur sommeil a une particularité.
Pour ne pas se noyer
en sombrant dans l'inconscience
l'animal bénéficie d'une
extraordinaire adaptation physiologique.
Il ne repose
qu'un hémisphère cérébral à la fois.
Littéralement,
il ne dort que d'un œil.
Sans transition,
la tempête reprend ses droits.
En moins de dix minutes,
la douceur printanière
se transmue en violence hivernale.
La mer, elle aussi se fâche.
Prudentes,
les orques s'éloignent du rivage.
Comment font ces éléphanteaux
âgés de quelques jours à peine,
pour résister à la furie des éléments ?
Passant outre les rafales démentielles,
un petit tète comme si de rien n'était.
La tempête forcit.
Se mettre à l'abri devient impératif.
Mes tentatives de prise
de vues m'ont laissé transi.
Sans ma tente,
aucune chance de survie.
Je me sens soudain bien seul.
Tellement vulnérable
par rapport aux animaux
de ces contrées extrêmes.
Les bourrasques
ont un relent de fin du monde.
Y aura-t-il une limite
à la puissance de cette tempête ?
J'ai vécu une nuit de cauchemar,
terrorisé à l'idée que mon abri
allait être emporté par la tourmente.
Mi-octobre,
les femelles arrivées les premières
s'apprêtent déjà à retourner à l'océan.
Elles ont allaité
leurs bébés durant trois semaines
et fait tout
ce qu'elles pouvaient pour lui.
Fécondées par le pacha,
elles reviendront dans un an
donner le jour à
une autre petite boule de poils.
Cette éléphante est
sur le point de partir.
Son bébé n'est pas
encore sevré et veut la suivre.
Elle l'en dissuade avec autorité.
Cet étrange
comportement d'abandon s'explique.
La maman manque de réserves
de graisse pour terminer l'allaitement.
Peut-être a-t-elle l'intention de revenir
après avoir fait le plein d'énergie.
Fatiguée,
elle entre dans l'eau sans discrétion.
Erreur fatale.
La coordination
de l'attaque est parfaite.
Arrive le moment du partage.
Chez les orques,
la solidarité est une vertu cardinale.
Désormais seul,
le bébé est le témoin impuissant
du drame dont il est aussi la victime.
À la différence des manchots
nourris par leurs deux parents,
les éléphanteaux ne peuvent
compter que sur leur mère pour survivre.
Celui-ci n'a pas tiré le bon numéro
à la grande loterie
de la vie des mers australes.
Affamé, décharné,
il est désormais une proie sans défense
et les oiseaux le savent.
Sa seule chance de survie,
téter une autre femelle.
Malheureusement,
son espèce n'est pas altruiste.
Aucune maman n'a assez
de réserve pour nourrir deux petits.
L'orphelin quémande en vain.
Les autres jeunes
le dénoncent à leur mère protectrice.
La sanction est immédiate.
Je suis désemparé face
au destin tragique de ce petit.
Je ne peux rien faire pour l'aider.
Impossible de remplacer sa mère.
Cruellement mordu, rejeté de tous,
il est rattrapé par
la terrible loi de la sélection naturelle.
Jamais il ne connaîtra
le goût du poisson du large.
Jamais il ne deviendra pacha
pour laisser une descendance sur cette île
du bout du monde.
Mi-novembre,
la majorité
des femelles a regagné le large
et le harem a fondu
comme neige au soleil.
Le pacha s'active encore
à féconder ses dernières concubines.
Il partira bientôt à son tour.
Trois semaines après leur naissance,
les éléphanteaux sont définitivement
livrés à eux-mêmes.
Ils se rassemblent en crèche.
Un bon moyen
de se rassurer les uns les autres
et d'oublier l'absence de maman.
Ils découvrent les plaisirs
des chahuts et des longues siestes.
Ils ont mués.
Noire à la naissance,
leur fourrure est devenue gris clair.
Mais le changement de costume
provoque d'insupportables démangeaisons
qu'il faut calmer
d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Les jeunes comme les adultes
adorent se gratter.
David le sait
et il ne résiste pas à la tentation
d'exploiter ce péché mignon.
J'ai conscience que
ce n'est pas un comportement scientifique.
Mais comment résister
à l'appel de ces peluches ?
Il me semble
que j'ai une excuse.
Ces boules de poils
ont investi allègrement mon campement.
Un premier pas, peut-être,
pour m'inviter à me joindre à eux.
Je me laisse volontiers influencer
par la confiance qu'ils me témoignent.
Ces échanges sont le signe
d'une véritable acceptation.
Un imprévisible cadeau.
Les jeux que ces éléphanteaux partagent
avec moi constituent la plus simple
et la plus essentielle
des communications.
Je goûte avec eux
un moment de grâce naïve,
qui me ramène allègrement
sur les sentiers de ma propre enfance.
Décembre, l'estomac
désespérément vide,
les éléphanteaux
se rapprochent du rivage.
Inconscients du danger,
ce sont des proies faciles.
À la différence des jeunes orques,
ils devront tout apprendre par eux-mêmes.
Pour certains,
le voyage s'achèvera à peine commencé
dans un claquement
de mâchoires géantes.
Cette lourde mortalité infantile traduit
pour les prédatrices un indispensable
apport d'énergie avant l'hiver.
Dans un mois,
il ne leur restera plus
que des manchots pour se nourrir
et peut-être au péril de leur vie,
les poissons tirés des abysses par
l'un de ces dangereux bateaux de pêche.
Avant leur départ
en direction de l'Antarctique,
David veut filmer les éléphanteaux
dans le milieu qui est désormais le leur,
la mer.
Je le cherchais
et c'est lui qui m'a trouvé.
Les mordillements de l'animal
ne sont-ils pas l'expression
d'une sympathique moquerie ?
Comme pour me dire
est-ce que tu as besoin
de ce déguisement ridicule
pour venir dans mon univers ?
Pourquoi est-il parti ?
Est-ce un adieu ?
La réponse est écrite noir sur blanc.
La matriarche est-elle
à la poursuite de l'éléphanteau ?
Pour la première fois,
le mâle s'approche de moi.
Huit mètres de long,
plus de huit tonnes.
Aussi impressionnant qu'un TGV.
La matriarche revient vers moi.
C'est l'heure du contact.
Grâce à leur sonar perfectionné,
les orques m'échographient de la tête
aux pieds,
je suis mis à nu.
comme un nouveau-né,
je suis vulnérable.
Les chasseresses le savent
et je m'abandonne à ce que je pense
pouvoir nommer leur sagesse.
Un échange s'instaure,
fait d'un intense je-ne-sais-quoi.
Dans cette gueule ouverte,
je vois un début de communication.
Nous avons exorcisé
nos craintes mutuelles.
J'ai la profonde intuition
que cette femelle est celle
que les hommes ont sauvée autrefois.
Devenue chef de clan, elle a
voulu en savoir plus sur moi
avant d'exposer
son groupe à un danger potentiel.
Aujourd'hui,
elle a compris que je viens en paix.
Les orques se livrent à moi
comme je me suis livré à elles.
Ultime reconnaissance
envers l'espèce humaine
pour avoir sauvé l'une d'entre elles.
Aucun mot ne saurait peindre
l'émotion que je ressens
dans ce moment de sublime partage.
Cet élan d'affection dépasse
mes rêves les plus fous.
Je suis rassuré de savoir
que les orques conservent leurs traditions
malgré la présence
des bateaux de pêche.
En réponse aux massacres
perpétrés par les pirates autour de Crozet
les orques se sont d'abord
montrées prudentes à mon égard.
Comment leur reprocher de se méfier
d'une espèce
particulièrement destructrice ?
Pourtant, dans ce monde
où leur avenir est compromis par l'homme,
elles ont fait preuve de discernement.
Elles ont finalement décidé
de m'entrouvrir
les portes de leur royaume.
Prédatrices par excellence,
si elles sont parfois cruelles,
elles savent aussi se faire aimer.
À Jamais, je serai transformé
par ces rencontres improbables.
Sur cette île des tempêtes
où la vie est une lutte de chaque seconde,
les animaux sauvages
ont accepté ma présence.
Ils m'ont confié
quelques uns de leurs secrets
et surtout,
ils m'ont témoigné leur confiance.